hi my name is hans klavers i'm a
scientist in the netherlands
what you see here is the uh the gut of a
of a mammal
could be a mouse would be a human being
you already start appreciating that the
inner surface has these
protrusions that extend the surface of
the gut dramatically this helps us to
very efficiently digest food and take up
nutrients
the cells on those villi are exposed to
a very threatening biological
environment as you might realize and
that is probably the reason why they
only live for a few days and they're
constantly being replenished by
cells that come out of these structures
that are called crypts you see them here
and in the story that i'm going to tell
i try to to show you that these
multicolored cells at the base of the
crypts are the stem cells that drive
this incredibly active self-renewal
process
the crypts of libercoon were named after
this guy a german young scientist who
defended his thesis several centuries
ago in leiden in the netherlands he sees
this was only 32 pages it was actually
in latin and with google translate we
managed to figure out what he had done
he actually had
infused hot wax into
human organs mouse organs
cooled the organs down
then digested away the tissue and
through a magnifying glass and using
etching techniques he would then produce
an image of what he was seeing and you
can see the vascular skeletons of the
microvilli in the in this piece of
tissue looking from the inside and when
he flipped it around
there were blood vessels clearly on the
outside of the gut but you might also
appreciate that here and here there are
these tiny white circles he realized
they were protruding small spaces
outward from the lumen of the gut and
they call them crypts and we now know
that these are the homes of the stem
cells of the intestinal tract this is a
much more modern view of the same
structure so here you see a villus you
see many other villi in the background
this is a crypt of libercular about uh
eight to ten or so that's around the
base of the of the villas um cells are
constantly being produced by then
enigmatic stem cells that reside
somewhere near the base of the crypt
their daughters very rapidly proliferate
they take two days to reach the axis of
the crypt they then differentiate out
into one of the number of cell types
that you see here they move up
the the villas and about four or five
days after they are born they reach the
tips of the villi that you see here and
they undergo apoptosis they commit
suicide
and with that i'd like to thank you very
much for your attention
you